Mayonnaise, but don't be scared of making it.
Basically all it is is emulsification of raw egg yolks and groundnut oil.
Groundnut oil because it's a neutral oil, it's not flavored.
Three egg yolks, teaspoon of English mustard.
And the mustard gives the mayonnaise a little bit of heat.
Now, lid on.
If you haven't got a mixer, you can whisk it by hand but this is a lot quicker.
Once you've mixed it, this is where it's really important that we add the oil slowly.
The first 30 seconds of making a mayonnaise is the most crucial.
Slowly with the oil, that stops it from splitting.
This is 300 ml of groundnut oil.
Drizzle into the eggs.
And you never season mayonnaise until the end.
When you season it to begin with, it destroys the egg yolks.
Now we can add the oil a little bit quicker.
You can just hear that sound when it goes from liquid to really nice, thick mayonnaise.
Now season it, salt, pepper, fresh lemon juice.
That gives it a really nice sort of zesty freshness, makes it exuberant.
And then just a quick blast.
And what we're looking for is this really nice, soft, creamy textured mayonnaise.
Beautiful!
Looks fantastic and tastes delicious.
Right.
Keep it in the fridge.